a
aujourd'hui plus que jamais peut-être il
faut être prudent dans les deux affaires
dramatiques qui occupe la une de
l'actualité je veux parler d'abord de la
sphère de l'assassinât du petit grégory
dans laquelle les jours et les vérités
se suivent sans forcément se ressembler
dernier élément en date les avocats de
l'inculpé bernard laroche sont ressortis
hier soir d'une confrontation entre leur
client et sa belle-soeur qui
l'innocentent après l'avoir accusé
ressorti en déclarant que plusieurs
pièces manquaient au dossier que le juge
d'instruction leur avait communiqué on
l'aura en or avait pas remis d'études
graphologique de bernard laroche par
exemple alors que tout le monde pensait
jusqu'à présent que c'était justement
cette étude entre autres qu'il avait
fait soupçonner sur place notre envoyé
spécial isabelle bechler essaie de nous
dresser la liste des questions qui
restent en suspens
une langue après midi de confrontation
va commencer pour bernard laroche qui
arrivent ici en comptant cellulaire de
la prison charles iii à nancy à 14h30
bernard laroche est toujours l'assassin
présumé du petit grégory villemin
surtout en raison de trois témoignages
contradictoires de muriel sa jeune belle
soeur de 15 ans qu'il va retrouver dans
le bureau du juge
dehors marie-ange laroche est accompagné
de louisette jacob et de sa fille
chantal elles doivent témoigner tout
deux car c'est dans leur maison que
l'inculpé affirmé regarder la télévision
à l'heure du rap du l'enfant mais
louisette et sa fille sont handicapées
mentales
au palais les avocats se battent pied à
pied ils font citer des témoins
supplémentaires qui vont confirmer on
l'apprendra plus tard point par point la
libye de bernard laroche quand il
sortait le coup de théâtre il incrimine
un dossier vide et mal construits ils
sont en colère contre le juge et la
manière dont a été mené l enquête nous
attendons un communiqué
regardez vous publiez un tout unique
mais maintenant oui vont faire aucun
rapport de topsy ne figure dans le
dossier d'instruction et des documents
graphologique n'y figurent pas non plus
contrairement aux informations diffusées
il n'existe à ce jour dans le dossier
qu'une seule expertise graphologique
cette expertise qui émane de monsieur
argoud et qui a été fait à la demande de
la gendarmerie
conclut à la présomption de culpabilité
d'un tiers
dont la libye là semble-t-il même pas
été vérifiée ce tiers n'est pas bernard
laroche nous sollicitons la mise en
liberté de bernard laroche
non le juge d'instruction a cinq jours
pour entendre les témoins à charge
rendre sa décision et faire
éventuellement de l'assassin présumé
laroche -un ancien suspect numéro un